jurgen Kazakh actively campaigns against
right-wing extremism he's organized
numerous actions to promote tolerance
even as neo-nazis have tried to
intimidate him into silence lessons
taught such results recently I
experienced a situation where a total
stranger accosted me on a street car in
live see where I normally feel safe
kenna own in certain places in
situations i found i really have to keep
my wits about me foodie's lung it's made
me a bit paranoid Paul knew you every
week for the past two years hundreds of
pegida followers have taken to the
streets to protest the government's
decision to open the country to people
seeking asylum so much so that it's rare
to find a local politician who will go
on record to speak out against it
publicly the CDU speaker for internal
affairs in saxony is one exception
bahamians cotton podemos we have
difficulties with right-wing extremism
fixed we must step up the political will
to address it that said not everyone
expressing an opinion or voicing
concerns about refugee policy is a
right-wing extremist plea to qu nett an
organizer at the anti-extremism group
hearts instead of hate hopes to get
thousands to turn out to their next
rally God nutlets to serve at Swansea
last year there were more than 20,000
people on the streets do not see groups
were rampaging through the city the
police let them run wild when they
attacked our rally the police just stood
by and did nothing to stop them this
year they're hoping their demonstration
for freedom equality and humanity will
come off without incident